yeah I just finished a harvard business
case study which is gonna be exciting
and now I'm walking into the four DS I'm
not wearing any shoes cuz [ __ ] Tyler
call me add sneakers in again hey hello
hello hello still dreaming like this
road even gets me like this gets all
different like pops was always round
like what see nothing missing
hi chipping I know some people had the
worst foot this cuz it's coming I don't
lessen my curse and for my dog behind
the wheel as we speak what Brad said
aside but you'll be working like you
can't eat keep dreaming dog keep
dreaming I know CJ's you wanna go for
pen in the schema yeah
got a speech piece right now I just had
a cool job interview forget about
everything else do you know what we're
gonna win because I don't care about
making any money this is a no-brainer
you know I forgot about this model cuz
this is like stuff I learned about like
years ago dude your this is good I'm
[ __ ] pump do it [ __ ] every day and
your underpants and your [ __ ] living
room have more people own the [ __ ]
data have the data they become your
leads not some [ __ ] random numbers
that called into some like it's it's
crazy better I have to exploit this this
is insane
that was not for DS is like been such an
incredible I I wish I could you know
sometimes in my like darkest moments at
Vayner I'm like I'm gonna sell Boehner
just do for DS just like spend 18 hours
a day with businesses and just [ __ ]
Jam you Soph I mean I love it yeah man I
love hell I love you it like I like the
historical videos right and I'm always
looking for those trends I'd I think
such a young group every one of us will
see two sports that don't even exist or
like in some weird subculture right now
that are gonna be mainstream right I
mean when you think about where eSports
soccer and UFC is today compared to
where they were when I was 21 years old
20 years ago either non-existent
couldn't even think about its existent
or it's never gonna happen here right
UFC was banned soccer will never happen
in America and eSports fundamentally did
not exist I'll talk to you later
yes what's that of course a journey want
to get in awesome thank you such a
pleasure nice to hear it's your name
sunjai sunjai yes love it see a really
good great talk it felt really good
about that you know I'd say hello guys
know on YouTube I love sports fun to
come sorry d-roc come together it's fun
to come to the NBA great great you know
business executives sports like FanDuel
you know just great setting like a lot
of fun I got going there there's some
good stuff what
[Music]
pterence you'd YouTube a little learning
moment talking to Tyler about some
strategy I say something about
experience
d-roc starts laughing and it's just
funny to watch both of them it's
unbelievable
what seems hard today becomes so easy
when you actually do it it's
unbelievable i queer thing out actually
it's like 80 push-ups raps [ __ ] raps
like like just watching you'll be able
to handle way more easier and you know
you - like it's just probably how I got
here right like 20 [ __ ] years of reps
you know reps
20 years of [ __ ] the responsibility
on my neck
it's how I eat [ __ ] all day better start
eating [ __ ] that's how you get paid okay
so Thank You Justin real pleasure man
what's up my dad from the wine library
yes thank you brother tell myself what's
up Thank You Man oops my man did a great
job a lot of fun appreciate it I'm sure
your work yeah I think this would be a
good one when do you guys hear it what
up YouTube
say hello what's going on YouTube tell
me tell me tell him how'd it go he kill
me how many guests have you had on this
show
I like a hundred and and am I the best
guest of all time now I mean it's a
pretty obvious you know in a
stratosphere all your own seriously on a
very serious note what do you think like
rank me all time on this show top three
who are the other two uh TJ Miller I
really liked okay and I don't know top
two top two [ __ ] TJ okay Hawaiian
shirt true name bill bill Thank You Man
what's up sis the sisters in the house
she's just hiding she's not doing a [ __ ]
she's like hides in the corner makes
four ten just gets paid that was good
what do you think you rock all right
let's go I know it's a nice family
reunion but let's get the [ __ ] out of
here you can see them getting better
with the Bloggie stuff right that's why
you've been down in the last two because
I've been so busy I've been able to do
anything to see it some people say
Network I see - this is why I win I see
different things that people say
seriously it's a real insight
didn't rip off like good this guy I see
I see a rat I see a rat 84 can you get
me 90 formatted who's this
nobody's supposed to call me right now
right yes
how's the podcast Bram sport yo
this is Gary Vaynerchuk
how are you this feels like a pretty
safe place to do it
I've been very disappointed by media
companies who were always trying to
figure out what am I gonna do for you
when I put out the show or this article
or this radio show and then when it came
to social to your point follow me follow
me follow me follow me
I get why it was the first time we put
numbers as a public domain it's a badge
right how many followers you got how
many that I get why it happened
it's why I'm so glad it happened because
I was able to see through that and I was
hacking the game that actually mattered
which was depth not with I mean it's
even this the hell am i doing on your
show right now like everybody in my
world is like this is not a good
allocation of your time
we've got businesses to run you've got
bigger shows that are you know I'm
saying no to CNBC and ESPN every day and
I'm here with you right now because I
like serendipity I like building depth
with people on the come-up I like that
you're gonna be able to use my name to
BIC to book bigger guests in a future I
like karma I think it's practical
I think audios gonna explode so I think
podcasts are gonna explode even more so
alexis skills I think Amazon is gonna
become a major player and the Amazon is
the one that could probably create if I
heard today Amazon a has launched and
it's a new social network called a I
would be like hey this has a shot just
cuz I believe in the people right so I
think there'll be one or two things five
years from now that everybody is on and
definitely in the youth I think that
somebody who's eight years old right now
in five years will be on an app every
day that we that does not exist I never
eat lunch or breakfast and here's why
I'm like tired like [ __ ] this food like
no wonder all of you don't work that
much you lunch
give our city bikes
their bikes d-roc he's gonna run around
New York City guys we have an alert
found some real Pinot Grigio she loved
it she was she loved it
Thanks we did it we found real Pinot
Grigio anybody looking for some real
baby girl hey you're looking for that
real from yelling about Pinot Grigio in
the streets of New York - going to one
of the most the largest most
conservative company because I do a
daily vlog I am double mic often get in
here let me get a photo with you
in the sash fan thank you brother so
cool to meet you nice let me show your
videos really really inspiring thank you
very much might as well right wait that
mean every possible thanks for coming
about to go do this talk for Cornell
Tech and Bloomberg's for excited great
vibes good crowd both friends like this
good friends thanks for having me have
you thought about monetizing your voice
that's incredible if you can give me two
power moves to consumer attention cuz
you have basically mastered the art of
video everybody and their mother watches
you so if you give me two parables that
you can use in the next 24 hours to get
in consumer attention what would they be
um I would become disproportionately
educated or at or start practicing very
aggressively in understanding how
Facebook Ads work Facebook ads are so
good you can create long tail clusters
42 year old Latino women that like the
New York Jets
okay now go make a video go make a
Spanglish video about the jet like the
ability for the micro target at scale
right like you know I have a video that
went berserk Oh which was it was
basically I was getting mad
no forty four-year-old thought
themselves as a not like like I was
watching all the 19 and 20 year olds
with all these opportunities I'm like
Jesus we're all the 40 50 60 year old
it's like have you heard you're gonna be
living longer than you think like let's
go get ours right so I made that video
and I went crazy because i targeted
forty to sixty year olds that watch
Shark Tank you know like like there's so
much capability in that I'd also you
know look I've got gift for gab you've
got crazy voice like you know like you
got to be smart about that like the
first three seconds really matter the
copy really matters the thumbnail really
matters everything matters I love how
people think these people the masked
millions of followers like because they
got lucky
you know like there's so much thought
that goes into what we do a lot of
testing and learning but Facebook video
YouTube is hard to break out very
facebook video less hard especially if
you have a couple hundred bucks per
video to try to get it to go heading to
see Ben Leventhal CEO Prezi his
babysitter just cancelled so instead of
the restaurant will go into his
apartment so great day
super enjoyed today a lot of good
content for you d Rock big day for D
Rock and YouTube big love love all of
you guys keep grinding keep hustling you
know all the cliches [ __ ] but most of
all I don't give a [ __ ] if [ __ ]
brandy the Macho Man Savage came from
the death went on my sock and then came
back to life and did two channels as my
favorite person of all time rest in
peace Randy Savage yeah I wouldn't give
a [ __ ] please never I mean that was such
a ridiculous thing to say to me you know
me so well like the [ __ ] the matter
with you I'm not even gonna do anything
done I'm gonna expand on it just
disappointed in you